Welcome back everyone this will be my brand
new marvel daredevil video there was a bunch
of announcements that marvel just made about
daredevil's storyline in the next couple of
series and cameos that he's going to have as
well as kingpin so we'll break it all down
because it all starts with she-hulk and is
carrying through next year in echo and then
the daredevil revival series on disney plus
the year after that if you're brand new to
the channel of course i'll be doing videos
for all those episodes when they release
be sure to subscribe to get everything but the
big new announcement is about what the story
is going to be for daredevil when he comes back
during the echo series what the character is going
to be like and what's going on with the kingpin
during those episodes too and what story they're
carrying forward into the daredevil revival series
after that so if it wasn't clear the echo series
episodes are filming right now they're going to
release next year during that series charlie cox's
daredevil and kingpin will be main characters
and supposedly daredevil is going to be in around
three of the six total episodes so about half
of the series and during the series along with
whatever the regular main plot is going to be
for echo they haven't completely revealed that
one of the big subplots is going to be daredevil
trying to find kristin ritter's jessica jones
and there have been rumors that she and daredevil
would both have cameo scenes during the she-hulk
episodes next month which are coming out really
soon of course i'll be doing videos for all
those episodes but that would be long before we
see jessica jones theoretically during the echo
series so if daredevil and jessica jones
are both appearing in she-hulk long
before that they might just appear in completely
different scenes or it might just be daredevil in
she-hulk and jessica jones might not come back
until echo there was also a funny picture that
kristen ritter took with mike coulter having a bit
of a reunion between jessica jones and luke cage
mike coulter said that was a coincidence but he
was game to come back as luke cage any time there
just haven't been any reports about that happening
anytime soon because he's mostly busy with another
series on a completely different network so i
think kevin feige wants to bring him back it's
just an availability thing but also during the
echo episodes daredevil is supposed to have his
new mcu costume and it's going to be a version of
the red and black one from the comics he's had at
least six different costumes in the comics there
was the all black prototype costume we saw that
at the beginning of the daredevil series and
again during daredevil season three just like
the regular cloth black one then his yellow and
black costume from the comics then his modern
red costume that we saw a version of during the
daredevil series a black and red armored costume
that was just used very temporarily and then the
new black and red costume that was used during the
shadowland saga this new one will be closer to
the all new all different volume one daredevil
costume the back and black costume like that's the
name of the title it's basically what's happening
with daredevil he is back in black in the mcu now
everybody queueing up the ac dc iron man would be
proud and supposedly the reason why he's looking
for jessica jones in the echo episodes is to
help set up a bigger return for her character
during the upcoming daredevil revival series
on disney plus and that would happen after the
echo episodes like that's why we're going to
see echo episodes then the year after that
we'll see the daredevil revival episodes
like kristin ritter's jessica jones will be
a bigger part of the daredevil revival series
they shared some scenes together during the
netflix defenders marvel series they both work in
the legal field so it makes sense that they would
run into each other fairly often through the court
system jessica jones is a private investigator
so she'd be like the person the daredevil would
call to help him gather evidence for cases or
get information from informants around the city
well right before he shot himself he said they
were going to take down the city obviously we know
now they are the hand was he one of them he said
he was one of the good guys and you believed him
i don't read heartbeats but i do read people even
though they're both vigilantes they do a lot of
leg work a lot of dirty work at night that's
pretty much all jessica jones does daredevil
also has to spend some of his time during the day
in the actual courtroom arguing on cases recently
there was also a weird report about disney plus
changing the name of jessica jones episodes from
jessica jones to aka jessica jones which was the
original title of the series when it was initially
in development at abc way before it ever became a
netflix series that's also the official title for
her comic book too aka jessica jones and they used
that aka title as references during the episode
titles of the series but then a little while ago
disney just came out and said that was actually a
bug like the series is meant to say jessica jones
it's not meant to be aka jessica jones it's just
like a one-time thing that they're gonna fix
but the big kingpin announcement is that when
he returns during the echo series he's gonna be
the main villain as you probably guessed because
of the way they set their relationship up like
you just got a teaser for that they didn't really
explore that too much because they were saving
a lot of that for the echo episodes the way they
ended his story in hawkeye was right out of the
comics like it's literally right off the page
here with echo trying to kill him by shooting
him in the face but only blinding him in the
eye so when he returns in those new echo
episodes he's supposed to be wearing an
eye patch how ironic given his relationship with
daredevil like he'll still have eyesight problems
but also one of the big things during his
storyline during echo and it'll continue
into the daredevil revival series episodes is
that during that he'll be running for mayor of
new york city like mayor kingpin was also a recent
story arc in the comics it'll be kind of like that
so what might happen is that he's running for
mayor during the echo series and then when the
daredevil revival episodes pick up he's named
mayor during those episodes in the comics the
whole thing that happened with that was during
the hydra captain america arc if you remember
that everybody kind of tried to forget it because
that was a very unpopular version of the character
kingpin winds up helping doctor strange in the
hero save new york city it was kind of like his
dark rain norman osborne moment at the end of the
secret invasion norman osborne a villain winds up
helping defeat the scrolls invading earth at the
time and takes all the credit for it he uses all
this new authority that the government gives him
in power to take over shield and the avengers and
turns them into the dark avengers replacing the
classic avengers that you all know with villains
like a thunderbolt's version of the avengers just
using them to do all kinds of really shady stuff
that he wants them to do basically using them
to push his own personal agenda during the mayor
kingpin story arc is basically the same situation
he winds up trying to take over new york city
but make it better with his iron fist so to
speak to make another defender's reference
and everybody's wondering what they're going to
do with that iron fist character in the future
but like kingpin wants to make new york city
great again so to speak because it just went
through this big tragedy during the hydra captain
america arc but with kingpin calling all the shots
so obviously it gets super dark he winds up
creating his own version of a thunderbolts
team of villains called the sinister syndicate
i know it sounds kind of like the sinister six
he uses them to do the same thing that norman
osborne uses the dark avengers for to just to
push his own personal agenda so it's like kingpin
trying to make new york city better but doing all
these super shady and outright criminal things
to do it during the original daredevil episodes
especially during daredevil season 3 this was
a big storyline kingpin never became mayor but
he did basically try to take over all the crime
families of the city take over the mob completely
becoming more like the comic book kingpin just
controlling the city trying to make it better
the way that he thought that it should be better
just making everybody do whatever he wanted them
to do because at the start of the series he didn't
have control of all the mob families it was until
the end of the series that that happened and he
became full comic book kingpin they also teased
kind of the same situation during the hawkeye
episodes with him controlling the tracksuit mafia
like it's after avengers end game it's after the
blip we just experienced this huge tragedy in the
mcu everyone's still kind of picking up the pieces
during the events of the hawkeye series and during
the hawkeye episodes vincent d'onofrio said that
he was supposed to be playing the same version
of the character from the original series like
the hawaiian shirt is right out of the comics
so they wanted him to look a little bit different
just visually but essentially he was meant to be
the same version of the character and most of
what happened during the daredevil episodes on
netflix are supposed to be canon but not like
every single little thing like most of it was
canon but not completely everything so like when
all these characters are coming back they're not
meant to be complete reboots of the characters but
the way that vincent d'onofrio talked about the
character he made it sound like he'd survived
through avengers infinity war he hadn't been
snapped lived through the events of the five-year
time gap in avengers end game the blip happens
and all those events had fundamentally changed
him and that's why he was a little bit different
at the beginning of the hawkeye episodes talk
about organized crime in the marvel universe and
you talk about the cd underbelly of new york city
there is one primary character that comes to mind
he said i want to bring you into the mcu and i'm
not going to say no to that like that's pretty
awesome i really loved playing this character i
liked creating him you know from the art of guys
like david mack fisk is really driven by emotion
you know he's like a child and a monster both at
the same time so it got very intense yesterday and
got a little bit intense today too i know when all
the daredevil characters come back kingpin comes
back there's going to be lots of questions about
continuity like what's canon what's not canon
anymore like i said most of it is supposed to be
canon but not every single little thing there were
a whole bunch of kingpin deleted scenes during the
hawkeye episodes i've already done videos on that
so i'll link those below in the description so you
can watch i'm not expecting to see an echo trailer
with daredevil or kingpin those characters till
like the very end of this year or maybe early next
year i don't know how many episodes daredevil is
supposed to be in during she-hulk it might just be
a small cameo scene like a really quick thing or
he might be in a couple episodes we'll find out
pretty soon we're getting ready to finish the
miss marvel episode so we're probably gonna get
a she-hulk trailer really soon i've already done
a much bigger video for the last she-hulk trailer
so i'll post that link in the description below so
you can learn about that because it's taking place
in los angeles on the other coast of the united
states if you have any questions about what's
going on during the new daredevil episodes or
daredevil cameo scenes and all the upcoming series
and all the big crossovers they have planned just
write those below in the comments and i'll try to
address them in my future bonus videos thor love
and thunder is also out this week i just posted
my review video for the movie so i'll link that
at the end of this in my post credit scene video
full easter eggs breakdown video for the movie
we'll start posting after it actually comes out
in theaters everyone click here for my full thor
love and thunder review video in easter eggs and
click here for my brand new loki season 2 first
look video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!